Now that we have factored each part of our fraction, we can remove the common
factors or simplify them since they equal one. For example, we know that this
quantity that X minus four divided by the quantity X minus four would equal one.
This would leave us with three times one which is three and five times one which
is five, or three 5th. We know we can do this because X really represents a
number, so if X were five we would be left with three times one and five times
one, which is 3 5th. But x doesn't have to be 5, it could be any number. If we
let x equal 6 then we plug in 6 for x and we get 3 time 6 minus 4 divided by 5
times 6 minus 4. This is really the same as 3 times 2 divided by 5 times 2. The
twos are factors that reduce to 1, so we really have 3 fifths. It wouldn't
matter what the value of x was. The quantity x minus 4 divided by the quantity x
minus 4 would always equal 1.